je vous le disais en titre un policier
de la brigade antique criminalité jugée
en ce moment devant le tribunal de Tours
le fonctionnaire de répondre de
détention d'image pédaux pornographiques
sur place au palais de justice on
retrouve Faustine uno Faustine bonsoir
le procureur la procureur vient de
donner ses réquisitions
être prisonnement avec sursis simple et
5 ans de suivi socio-judiciaire assortis
de soins ce après une heure de questions
à la barre face à la cour c'était un
policier qui semblait intimidé en
réponse aux interventions musclées de la
présidente du tribunal et de la
procureur il a donné des explications
assez confuses j'avais une curiosité
malsaine me poussant à aller chercher
tout ce que je pouvais a-t-il dit
j'étais dans mon monde pris dans ma
consommation d'internet je me sentais
comme un hacker l'accusé a admis avoir
commis les infractions pour lesquelles
il est jugé à savoir consultation
importation des tensions et diffusion
d'images pédopornographique pendant
plusieurs années notamment via le
Darknet et des sites pirt ou pire le
profil de ce policier un homme de 42 ans
père de deux enfants collègues
exemplaires qui admet avoir toujours
consommé de la pornographie parmi les
fichiers retrouvés sur ces ordinateurs
45 m'était en scène des adultes 200 des
enfants parfois en très bas âge ainsi
que plusieurs milliers de fichiers du
même type effacé je n'ai pas d'attirance
pour les enfants a-t-il pourtant assuré
j'ai honte je ne payais pas je n'avais
pas l'impression d'alimenter quoi que ce
soit c'est à dire un réseau
d'exploitation sexuelle de mineur
l'examen psychologique a pourtant révélé
selon le psychiatre une addiction à la
pédopornographie depuis de nombreuses
années le délibéré devrait être rendu
d'une minute à l'autre merci faustineau
en direct du tribunal judiciaire de
Tours